We started Fancy to connect people to the
things they love and people who share their
tastes.
We wanted to create an experience where you
could find the coolest things curated by the
coolest people, all available in one place.
Google Plus Sign-In is a better and more secure
way to connect with our site.
You already have a Google account, so you
don’t have to create a whole new username
and password.
You just click the button and you’re ready
to go.
Finding the things you love from the people
you trust.
Privacy is very important to users.
Sometimes you just want to share with your
friends.
family.
So signing in with Google gives you full control
over who you share with.
Sharing is not just about viewing.
It’s also about taking action.
So, you’re not just sending your friends
back to the app.
You’re inviting them to buy, or follow,
or contribute right there from the post.
And of course, mobile integration is huge.
With one click on the website, you can download
the app to any of your Android devices and
continue the experience on the go.
Google Plus Sign-In means simplicity and security.
And as we’re trying to connect you with
our site, we want to do that in the easiest,
most trustworthy way possible, so you can
focus on finding the things you love.